>> HERE'S A VERY CLEAR EXAMPLE
OF THE FRUSTRATION THAT APPEARS
TO BE BUILDING IN MOSCOW.
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT VLADIMIR
PUTIN GOT TESTY WITH HIS TRADE
MINISTER EARLIER ABOUT
FINISHING UP ORDERS FOR NEW
AIRCRAFT.
HAVE A LISTEN TO THIS.
>> YOU SAY EVERYTHING IS READY
TO GO, BUT THERE ARE NO
CONTRACTS.
THIS IS WHAT I AM TELLING YOU.
LET'S DISCUSS THIS AFTER THE
MEETING.
THERE'S NO POINT IN OUR
SPLITTING HAIRS AT THIS POINT.
I KNOW NO CONTRACTS HAVE BEEN
SIGNED WITH THE ENTERPRISES,
BUT DIRECTORS HAVE TOLD ME SO,
WHY ARE YOU FOOLING AROUND?
>> IT WILL BE READY DURING THIS
QUARTER.
BASED ON THE FUNDS AVAILABLE
UNDER THE BUDGET.
>> I WANT ALL OF THIS TO BE
DONE WITHIN A MONTH.
WHAT QUARTER ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT?
DO YOU NOT UNDERSTAND THE
CIRCUMSTANCES WE ARE IN?
PLEASE COMPLETE THIS WORK
WITHIN A MONTH.
AGREED?
>> WE WILL TRY TO DO OUR BEST.
>> NO, DO NOT TRY TO DO YOUR
BEST.
PLEASE, GET IT DONE IN A MONTH.
NO LATER.
>> WELL, PUTIN APPEARING THERE
TO LOSE PATIENCE.
THERE COULD BE SOME THEATER
GOING ON HERE.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
POLITICAL DYNAMICS THAT WE ARE
SEEING.
CNN'S SLUM KYLIE AS REPORTED
FROM UKRAINE AND THROUGHOUT
THIS WAR HAS BEEN IN AND OUT OF
THE COUNTRY FOR YEARS.
IN AND OUT OF RUSSIA.
HE'S JOINING US NOW FROM ABU
DHABI.
SAM, YOU'VE JUST BEEN IN
UKRAINE VERY RECENTLY.
YOU HAVE SEEN THE EVIDENCE OF
WHAT'S GOING ON ON THE GROUND
FROM BOTH A UKRAINIAN AND
RUSSIAN MILITARY PERSPECTIVE.
YOU ARE WELL AWARE OF WHAT THE
WAGNER GROUP IS UP TO FOR
EXAMPLE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS
INFIGHTING THAT WE HAVE BEEN
SEEING?
IT'S OBVIOUSLY SPILLING OVER
OUTSIDE OF THE MILITARY AT THIS
POINT GIVEN WHAT WE'VE JUST
SEEN THERE.
BETWEEN PUTIN AND HIS TRADE
MINISTER.
>> WASN'T THAT AN EXTRAORDINARY
SCENE?
I MEAN IT ECHOES, AND I DON'T
SAY THIS LIGHTLY, OF STALIN
THERE.
A MINISTER, CABINET MINISTER,
BEING PUBLICLY OPERATED FOR
FALLING BEHIND ON THE QUOTAS.
NOW, IF THE PATTERN OF THE OLD
SOVIET UNION IS TO BE REPEATED,
AND THIS HAS BEEN A CRITICISM
LEVELED AT PUTIN'S REGIME, BUT
ABOVE ALL AT HIS GENERALS, BY
NONE OTHER THAN PRIGOZHIN OF
THE WAGNER GROUP.
IF THEY ARE PURSUING A SOVIET
STYLE EFFORT HERE, THAT WHAT
WILL HAVE GOING ON IS THAT THE
GENERALS AND OTHERS WILL HAVE
STOLEN A LOT OF THE MONEY,
BRIEFED BACK UP THROUGH THIS
SYSTEM THAT EVERYTHING IS
ABSOLUTELY FINE, THAT THE PLANS
FOR THE INVASION OF KYIV WERE
ABSOLUTELY ROCK-SOLID, AND THEN
THEY ARE CONFRONTED WITH THE
REALITY ON THE GROUND WHICH IS
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN LYING ABOUT
THEIR MILITARY CAPABILITY.
THIS IS A MAJOR FRUSTRATION FOR
THE RUSSIANS ON TOP OF THEIR
VERY POOR DOCTRINAL APPROACH.
THEY HAVE BEEN COMPLETELY
OUTMANEUVERED, LITERALLY, AND
OUT FOUGHT BY THE UKRAINIANS,
WHO HAVE MUCH SMALLER FORCES
AND FEWER WEAPONS.
BUT BECAUSE THEY'VE HAD NATO
TRAINING, IT HAS COMPLETELY
CHANGED THE FORM OF WARFARE
THAT THEY ARE PURSUING ON THE
GROUND.
NOW, THE REASON THE WAGNER
GROUP IS ABLE TO BOAST ABOUT
ITS SUCCESS IS IT'S A VERY
LINEAR STRUCTURE.
IT HAS A CBO, IF YOU LIKE, AND
THEN IT HAS SUBORDINATES.
VERY FEW PEOPLE IN THE SYSTEM
TO BEND THE RULES.
WHAT WE ARE ALSO SEEING HERE
ARE GAINS, PERHAPS ECHOES OF
THE LATE SOVIET ERA, IS THE
FRAME OF THE SYSTEM AROUND
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
HE IS LOSING HIS TEMPER WITH
HIS CABINET MINISTERS.
HE'S LOSING HIS TEMPER WITH HIS
GENERALS.
WE'VE HAD TO RETREAT
REPLACEMENTS ON THE BATTLEFIELD,
THE COMMANDER IN THE EAST OF
UKRAINE.
NOW WE HAVE GERASIMOV, THE
AUTHOR OF THE MAIN DOCTRINE,
THE INTERNATIONAL DOCTRINE OF
RUSSIA IN TERMS OF MILITARY
OPERATIONS, WHICH IS
PERMANENTLY STABILIZATION,
CHAOS IN THE RANKS OF THE ENEMY
'S VICTORY.
THAT WILL BE WORRYING FOR THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY,
BECAUSE IT MEANS THEY WILL TRY
AND FREEZE THE BATTLEFIELD
WHERE IT IS.